now i showed you the leap to get from
here
right but i also showed you why it was
right to be suspicious
i think differentiation was worthwhile
because of this n minus one
okay so now looking at this question
what do you think we should do
it's n plus one and it's division rather
multiplication so this looks like
integration to me okay
so just like before let's start with
this identity
okay one plus x to the n
okay and let's integrate
both sides with respect to x okay so i'm
actually i'm going to be a bit lazy
i'm just gonna slap it in this first
line
okay so by the way don't forget your
dx's okay you have to integrate with
respect to something
so again chain rule here
right because the derivative of the
inside is one that's why it's easier to
handle okay so what happens i raise the
power up
and then of course i have to divide by
the power that i just got so that if i
differentiate
i'll come back i'll get back to where i
came from okay
all right now that's equal to um it's
just the x to the r
that i'm integrating right so you've got
this
and i'm going to raise the power and
divide by that power
okay but i'm missing something right
i integrated and it's an indefinite
integral
okay so i need a constant flying around
now remember because i've integrated
both sides
i don't need two constants okay because
if i've got a constant here got a
constant there take the difference
the difference of two constants is still
constant okay
so i'm just going to slap the constant
on one side okay
okay constant's there so now what
what do we usually do to get rid of a
constant
we usually have like initial conditions
or some point that the primitive
function passes through
and you sub it in and then that'll let
you find c
right because i don't really have any
initial conditions or anything like that
right what else could i possibly do here
to work out what
c is
now even though i don't have initial
conditions i do have some conditions
right
because this x which i introduced yeah
it's going to be equal to something
later on in order to fit with
what i was required to prove right so
what value of x
should i pick here that's going to make
this line look most like
what i'm required to prove
x equals one in fact very frequently
it's going to be x equals one okay
so i'll say let x equal to one
right therefore what am i going to get
on the left hand side
i've got 2 to the n
plus 1 on m plus 1
plus my constant now what happens over
here on the right hand side
you're going to get this sum
okay all right but hold on a second
some of these things are equal like this
this thing and this thing
they're both constants aren't they
aren't they
so this constant here
should be equal to this sum
that's just well look carefully at it
the top part is just the one right so
that's one over
r plus one
uh minus this
now i'm gonna pause there i think i've
held your hand enough
think about where you've got to end up
okay i'm pretty close
right look at what i've got over here
that's basically this
okay what do i need is that minus one
how do i get it in position
okay so i'm gonna give you a couple
minutes have a think